I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges are the oranges of the
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation look at my
african-american over here look at him
I want nothing that's what I want from
you great that's what I said I want
nothing I said it twice god bless you
god bless Israel God bless the
Palestinians and God bless the United
States thank you very much I know words
I had the best words this is a tough
hurricane one of the wettest we've ever
seen from the standpoint of water
I think there's blame on both sides and
I have no doubt about it
but you also had people that were very
fine people on both sides
if Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
I'd be dating her
[Music]
quiet quiet
go ahead she's she's asking a question
don't be rude don't be rude
don't be weird no I'm not gonna give you
a quote I'm not gonna give you a
question
you are fake news
I never attacked him on his look and
believe me there's plenty of subject
matter right there that I can tell you
Jake where to recur in fact I'll get
that with a piece of dandruff little
piece we have to make them perfect he is
perfect for people's thank you thank you
thank you
thank you everybody but what we want to
do is to replenish the searchin nursery
was fun any when you're a star they let
you do it
you can do anything whatever you want
grab them by the [ __ ] people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times as
opposed to once China has total respect
for Donald Trump and for Donald Trump's
very very large a brain and he referred
to my hands if they're small something
else must be small I guarantee you
there's no problem I guarantee I don't
remember he's gonna like I don't
remember I thought all baby that's what
I said we will have no choice but to
totally destroy North Korea Rocket Man
is on a suicide mission for himself
North Korea best not make any more
threats to the United States they will
be met with fire and fury like the world
has never seen
but we have some bad Umbra's here and
we're gonna get them out
you